let's go dress this is all right all
right you bros suggested this website to
me it's called agario I never played it
everyone is suggesting it so I'm just
gonna play it right now
online with the people here we go
salad ass is going
so I guess it's like that game of big
eats smaller and gets bigger but you
play it online oh you're mine old Kalu
getting slick come on [ __ ] oh god what
do we do in a smellin ass Melanie's
sucking me up
[ __ ] you a smellin [ __ ] Jesus Christ
some of them are [ __ ] huge
Lord Voldemort is number 10 the [ __ ] was
that please don't eat me maybe people
will show more respect now
[Music]
stop
you're never getting you piece of [ __ ]
can he not read this is just pissing me
off why do you breasts want to see this
[ __ ] goddamn I piss now [ __ ] read it
eat me
[ __ ] you ready it clearly says don't eat
me after me now
[Music]
Japan you look like a pair of tits come
on [ __ ] off
press okay so I can split myself my
pressing W alright maybe that's what I
needed to do oh I can eat
I hate someone else yes I'm the best
player in the world
all right we're doing good all right all
right all right I'm getting waist lower
now though I got a pretty good mass goin
hear me look at this [ __ ] okay now I can
eat [ __ ]
I love eating [ __ ] come on let me eat
you
I screwed to tighten all Nazi Germany
I'm coming for you [ __ ] come on Nazi
Germany [ __ ] Hitler [ __ ] all
right someone I didn't I'd someone huge
what that [ __ ] come on baby come on [ __ ]
er come on keeper be a good game
what the [ __ ] happened what the [ __ ] is
this oh my god ah suck it all suck
together stick together stick together
for the kids
then [ __ ] is this faithless [ __ ]
spaceship space what the hell are you
stop stop I never asked for this Kim /
Kim / don't touch me
Tata please save me
[Music]
[ __ ] yeah justic don't eat me can you
read my [ __ ] name [ __ ] stop
ejecting yourself dog eat no no please
no doggy
please doggy please Sweden Sweden better
not [ __ ] hurt me I'm coming for your
origin no one likes you origin
oh [ __ ] Origen got right oh [ __ ] oh my
god this is bad this is real bad gotta
get the told oh god oh my god the dick
has surrounded me the giant ass penis I
did it somehow I did it with my tactics
earth I know what you're thinking earth
and yes I am going to eat your [ __ ]
[ __ ] out Oh God
yes no no this is a very bad situation
Stone it back oh oh
[Music]
yes mother pudding pie will eat you
fuckin'-a
you're [ __ ] a sellout Mon let me eat
you [ __ ] let me [ __ ] eat you I can't
stop playing I can't stop this is
[ __ ] amazing if I if I was selling
high school this is literally all I
would be doing with my life
I'm pretty sure I'm gonna have to end
that it's over there
now you know what I'll play one more
kiss [ __ ] you that's why [ __ ] you that's
why
[ __ ] pent the grand girl up oh [ __ ]
look at that [ __ ] he really wants me
look at him
I never seen someone so horny for me
look at that [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh god he got me thank you
sorry sorry this game is doing weird
things to me
oh no not to patriarchy anything but
what that's [ __ ] you know okay fine
you know what
fine you don't want to play anymore fine
[ __ ] you [ __ ] everyone [ __ ] away this
game but please do leave a like if you
enjoyed watching it helps me out a lot
it supports my videos and it makes me
feel like oh I like my video I'm so
happy
leave a comment about any meme you like
and I will I will continue scratching my
balls and then Oh kiss my hand and that
I scratched my balls stay awesome bros
it's coming from my neighbor it's coming
from a neighbor it's coming from my
label and his neighbor's use I love me I
love you and I especially love neighbor
Jews